Star Wars: The Last Jedi has arrived at last,
leaving audiences thrilled, amazed, and emotionally
spent — not to mention totally wondering
exactly what the heck is going to happen next.
Unfortunately, that "next" isn't going to
arrive until Episode IX hits theaters in 2019,
but at least that gives fans plenty of time
to speculate about just what we're likely
to see when this story finally concludes.
With that in mind, here's a spoiler-filled
look at some of the biggest unanswered questions
in The Last Jedi.
Why did Luke die?
Just as it seemed all hope was lost for the
Resistance at the end of The Last Jedi, the
actual last Jedi showed up with a new hope
in the form of a cool Force projection from
across the galaxy.
And then, after giving the others time to
escape, he dropped dead...for no apparent
reason.
But why?
Was the strain of projecting himself across
the galaxy too much?
Did Kylo Ren's lightsaber attacks somehow
actually injure Luke in the same way Kylo
was able to reach out and physically touch
Rey from across the galaxy?
Or did Luke simply become one with the Force
after redeeming himself and finally finding
balance?
All we know for sure is, like Yoda before
him, Luke just suddenly raptured on out of
there, leaving behind nothing but a sweaty
old Jedi snuggie.
Why, though, is anyone's guess.
Were Snoke's guards actually Luke's other
students?
When Luke explains to Rey what happened between
him and Kylo Ren, he states that Ben Solo
turned to the Dark Side, slew several of Luke's
other students, and then took off with the
rest.
So what happened to those other students?
Is it possible they ended up as Snoke's personal
guards?
After all, those mysterious red clad warriors
were almost powerful enough to take out Kylo
Ren and Rey at the same time.
Of course, if those were Luke's other students,
why wasn't anybody looking for them and trying
to save them instead of only worrying about
Kylo Ren all the time?
And if they weren't Luke's other students,
does that mean some of Luke's other students
might still be alive somewhere?
Hmm...
Is Snoke really dead?
There was a ton of speculation over the last
couple years over Supreme Leader Snoke's true
identity.
And then he abruptly got cut in half with
a lightsaber, making all that speculation
pointless.
Whoops!
But is he really dead?
One of the leading theories about Snoke's
true identity was the idea that he was actually
Darth Plagueis, a Sith Lord who was so incredibly
powerful, he actually mastered death itself.
If that's true, then it's possible Snoke could
possibly return from the dead in Episode IX.
And hey, Darth Maul somehow came back from
being cut in half by grafting weird spider
legs to his torso.
So is the galaxy going to be menaced by Zombie
Snoke?
Let the next two years of speculation begin.
What are they going to do with Leia?
When Carrie Fisher tragically passed away
in 2016, fans couldn't help but wonder how
it would affect the Star Wars universe.
While Fisher had already finished filming
her scenes as General Leia for The Last Jedi,
Disney reportedly had to completely rework
the story for Episode IX to deal with the
loss of one of the franchise's most beloved
characters.
But how exactly are they going to handle it
in the story?
At the end of The Last Jedi, Leia is still
leading the ragtag group of survivors from
the Resistance, and is confident she has all
the tools she needs to reform the movement
and drive out the First Order.
But since Disney is reportedly not going to
use any footage of Fisher in Episode IX, or
use CGI to recreate her as they did in Rogue
One, it leaves a major question mark about
how they'll explain her absence.
Why is Luke really on the island?
When Rey shows up and asks for Luke's help,
he very rudely tells her to get lost, informing
her that he came to the island to die in peace.
Which is a nice line and everything, but it
doesn't make a lick of sense.
For starters, if he wanted to die, why is
he... still, like, alive?
And more importantly: if he really wanted
to be alone so darn badly, why did he leave
behind a detailed map showing exactly how
to find him?
The whole thing seems like the Jedi equivalent
of vaguebooking: he really went away because
he just wanted someone to come find him and
ask what's wrong.
And you thought Kylo Ren was the emo one.
What's in the cave?
Jedi trainees sure do love going into evil
caves to confront the Dark Side.
But Rey's trip into the blowhole of ultimate
evil left us with more questions than answers.
When she first senses the cave, Luke is horrified
at how willingly she approaches the darkness
that dwells within.
but not horrified enough to cancel the next
lesson...They agree that there must be something
Rey needs inside the cave, something that
calls to her.
And yet, when she actually goes inside to
find out what the deal is, she only finds
a mirror that provides her with… nothing
at all.
So what was Rey drawn to in the cave that
was so important?
Because whatever it is, she didn't seem to
actually find it.
What are Leia's powers?
Fans have been salivating at the idea of Leia
becoming a Jedi knight since it was first
revealed in Return of the Jedi that she's
Luke's sister and can also use the Force.
But other than occasionally gazing into the
middle distance and mumbling someone's name,
she never seemed to use any of her powers
— until The Last Jedi, when she suddenly
went full on star wizard in a crazy sequence
when she used her abilities to survive the
vacuum of space and even fly through it.
Which begs the question: how the heck did
she do that?
When did she undergo training?
What else can she do?
Leia's powers have never been explored, but
flying around in space like you're Iron Man
or something suggests that Leia has a whole
bag of tricks we never knew about — and,
sadly, are never likely to see again.
What does porg taste like?
It's true that Last Jedi leaves a lot of questions
open to debate.
But for our money, the one question we really
want answered is what porg tastes like.
In one of the most wrenching scenes in the
film, Chewbacca tries to eat a roast porg,
only to be accosted by the poor beast's distraught
family.
They try to guilt him into not eating their
cousin, although by that point, the damage
was kind of already done.
And it looked delicious, like a juicy, tender
chicken roasted to perfection.
But does it taste like chicken?
Or, as the name implies, is it closer to pork?
Porg: the other, other white meat?
It does kind of have a ring to it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!